greek mythology is full of tragedy and
heartbreak and there are few stories as
sad as orpheus and eurydice orpheus was
a renowned poet and musician you could
say he was greek mythology's most famous bard
eventually he met the woman of his dreams eurydice
and together they got married on their wedding
day she came across a disgruntled sata fearing
for her life she ran unfortunately the grass
was tall and she fell into a nest of vipers
dying to a snakebite orpheus was overcome with
grief every song he played was full of so much
sadness and sorrow even the gods wept for him
travel to the underworld and find your wife they
advised and so orpheus embarks on a journey
to the underworld to find his lost love once
there his music was able to convince hades and
persephone to return his wife to him with only
one condition eurydice would have to walk
behind the orpheus until they got to the surface
he could not turn around before they reached the
surface orpheus could resist no longer and turned
to see his wife's face and she vanished right in
front of his eyes this time lost to him forever